what's your earliest memory of
YouTube
uh when I did my first video I
remember my first video was uh I played
Minecraft no one knows this but
Minecraft it was before it wasn't as
like uncool I guess it was when it was
in Alpha I remember uh I don't think
other people were even making videos of
it back then and uh I was I was so
intrigued by the idea that you could
record yourself playing games I thought
that was the coolest thing ever like
even before years before even YouTube
was a thing I was like I want to record
playing games that's so cool um and was
the Minecraft experience the first time
you ever did that and the Minecraft
because I finally got a computer that I
could actually record on so I was like
all right this is my first time well
this the first time I recorded speaking
while playing do you still have that
video no I I search everywhere for that
video so I submitted it to Machinima
Machinima respawn um and I found the
email but the the Dropbox link is dead
it's a shame I remember it so clearly
like I went I went into a cave there was
a skeleton I did my scream or whatever
because it scared me and I thought it
was so funny I sent it to my friend and
he thought it was so funny it was [__]
guaranteed so [__] but um that that was
my first video and I did it because I
thought it was so
weird that I didn't have any subscribers
so I thought I had to submit it
somewhere else so I would get some
subscrib does that make sense I don't
know because you watch everyone else on
YouTube and they're always talking to
their audience I didn't have an audience
who was I making videos for who am I
talking to in the microphone so who are
you talking I don't know it was so weird
to me I was like this is the weirdest
thing ever I'm alone with a microphone
in a room what the [__] is happening
like and what was your Minecraft
avatar I didn't I didn't have a
Minecraft avatar I wasn't that
Nery so you just went out into there as
the standard character and that was I
was pey all right pey yeah and so how
how far back does being pey
go
um about in when I started YouTube yeah
I started PewDiePie were there other
people on YouTube that you were watching
in the very beginning uh yeah I was
watching um C naners and Hutch they were
the two biggest Call of Duty guys or
whatever and uh I thought it was so cool
talking over when you're playing a game
I really really like that idea I never
seen anyone else do it and had you done
a lot of online gaming talking to to
friends and
stuff what do you mean what well like
you know being on Xbox Live or whatever
so me and my friends the way we were
social was to we would go to a net cafe
together it's like hey let's all hang
out to go to this dark room where we all
just sat and stared in front of the
screens but for us that was very social
because we were still sitting next to
each other we're still screaming at each
other um playing games how old were you
when you first went to a net cafe 14
probably I was 14 and you had a computer
in your house but you guys just wanted
to do it together yeah because obviously
my parents and everyone else's parents
didn't want you to play as much so as
soon as you get the stop like okay you
play too much now you need to go outside
all right we'll go outside but we'll go
to a net cafe and we'll just do the same
thing but there and there it's like
undisturbed fun atmosphere and what were
the games that you really love to play
we we would always play moas like uh
DOTA and League of Legends I guess now
it's
popular and would there be girls there
as well so many
girls no there would be no girls there
what are you talking about there was one
guy that kept bringing his girlfriend
there I remember and it was always like
what are you doing she clearly wasn't
interested at all I remember she just
sat there like why am I
here so were there many conversations
with your parents about the amount of
gaming that you were doing and their
concerns about it yeah yeah yeah I would
always had to hide me playing games from
my parents
definitely um yeah is there like uh do
you ever bring those conversations up
with them again these days yeah we kind
of joke about it a little bit because
they were very strict about it like you
can't play games this is not good for
you cuz they know me like I'm
very uh obsessive sometimes if I get
really into a game I well YouTube
clearly as well if I really get into
something I really do it 100% And I
think that has always been games for me
and I think they were worded for my
future that I wasn't you know didn't see
a future in gaming I think like most
parents you're not going to get anywhere
playing games or whatever somehow I
managed to find a way to do that and
yeah now we can joke about it what did
they have in mind for
you oh well I don't know I guess I I
studied the same thing my mom did for a
while which was industrial management
and economy uh same school my parents
met
at uh so kind of following their steps
mainly because I didn't really know what
I wanted to
do and and and what kind of career do
you think that you were going to end up
with following their steps and in
University um what does your mother do
my mother is she works with it
uh um she I don't know what she did does
I
know she she's been CEO um no C CTO no
oh CIO she chief engineer officer no
that's not how you spell whatever this
is G Chief Information officer that's it
Chief Information is that it well okay
well my mom works with it my dad sort of
similar and I guess they wanted kind of
like the same same same thing for me did
they read the YouTube
comments no I don't think so I know I I
guess they do yeah she my mom loves to
read cuz she's in one video she loves to
read the comments on that
one how is it to Sho that video it a bit
awkward yeah I think and you had your
sister in that one as well yeah yeah but
it was very funny they were funny had it
been something you'd wanted to do to get
them involved in a video for a long time
no they be practically beg me to be in
the video it's funny cuz
I I really don't care about getting
attention or anything like that but my
my not not in a bad way but my mom and
sister they love the attention they love
like reading comments and stuff like
that about themselves so they they
wanted the video but I was for me it's
like cuz my dad was like I don't really
want to be in this video cuz he's like
me like I don't really care about that
so was he dead that day yeah he was on
the couch next to us yeah and so uh have
you ever thought about making videos
with them yeah definitely I just don't
see them that often and it feels a bit
weird hey haven't seen you in a while
let's shoot a video like it doesn't no
it doesn't seem right do you miss Sweden
[Music]
no
no how how much of a thing when you were
going up was it the idea of moving away
from Sweden I never hit my mind no I
never thought I would leave Sweden ever
it's really strange cuz you you grow up
in in a bubble of this is everything
that matters to me inside this territory
or whatever and then you leave your
country and you're like whoa there's a
whole world I didn't even think about it
seems to so small just my hometown not
to be like I'm bigger than my hometown
but it seems so small in comparison any
broaden your perspective how many people
live in your hometown half a million
maybe yeah and and then when did it
strike you that you should move out of
Sweden well
the idea never to move never hit me
until I met Maria I think
um I wanted to be with her no matter
like we just knew we wanted to be
together
so I think when I met her I think when
it hit me and and where did you where
were you and what were you do when you
first heard the name here uh summertime
in Sweden a lot of girls around but I
was focusing on this girl online instead
uh uh which was really fun and uh yeah I
was Harbor captain in
the
uh in the summer City that I was in fic
sh and uh what does a harb captain do we
tell the other boats where they can park
their boats it's basically like a park
ballet for
boats and you don't even get to park the
boats yourself no you're literally just
tell them where they par it sounds so
prestigious Harbor Captain but it's
really no it's pretty [__] captain of of
the harbor right it's as simple as that
and had you ever had like a friendship
or relationship that started on the
internet before um yeah just once sort
of but it never really L anywhere so
yeah no Marti was definitely the first
time we felt serious about I think with
online relationship is easy to never
never meet you just keep talking and
then it just kind of like you can only
go so far if you never met it's kind of
weird so I knew I was like I just want
to meet this girl right away and not
waste time and that's sort of what I did
I kind of dive in pretty quick with
Maria and and and but how long was it
that you were able to uh go from first
talking to herline to actually meeting
her person uh Mar say was uh two months
I think I met her we started talking at
the beginning of the summer and then by
the end of the summer with the money I
got from my Harbor Captain I uh I went
to see her at the end of the summer and
and when you were talking with her you
were talking over Skype or yeah we were
talking over no actually Mara was pretty
shy so she didn't want to talk over
Skype directly so it was always in the
back of my mind like I'm being catfished
here like this this could be some dude
where we would send videos to each other
instead and uh I think I had like one or
two videos of her the rest was just
pictures or like uh we just wrote to
each other and her English wasn't very
good in the beginning so it would take
like 20 minutes with like a normal
message cuz she had to like she told me
her friend was sitting next to her every
time just like reading all the messages
and I'm like great you showed all that
to your friend did you keep the videos
that she sent you at the very beginning
yeah yeah I have those you're not going
to see them though they're actually on
well the ones I said are like privated
on my channel
so
dangerous and and and how so you were
actually recording videos for the
audience of one I her yeah is this
before you were doing videos for YouTube
I I was doing videos on YouTube I had
started like half a year before that did
you put the same kind of preparation
that you put into a YouTube video into a
video that you'd send her yeah pretty
much yeah like a solo video yeah I think
so what was it um about her that first
stood out as really special
um well she was
beautiful I think that was the main
thing cuz she wrote me and I'm like
who's this hot
girl uh what did she
say I don't know I don't remember she
just wanted to talk I remember she told
me that I was very like forward right
away toally I was like I'm going for it
uh
so what was question what I noticed with
her
we just connected really well I think it
was really just fun to talk to her and I
um yeah what were the main things you
had in common not much really I don't
think much at
all I think we just enjoyed each other's
company pretty much and so paint a
picture of what happened when you took
your final Harbor Captain check got a
ticket well I got I got fired from har
haror
Captain why' you get fir um well there
was a golden eye this huge boat I wanted
to come to our Harbor and I got so
excited I'm like the golden eye is
coming this is my big moment as Harbor
Captain so they call me and they're like
we're the golden KN we'd like to visit
your Harbor and I'm like holy [__] uh
but we're a small there was a tiny tiny
Harbor we clearly didn't have space for
the golden eye how big is the Golden Eye
uh the golden eye was like like a y
in a small Swedish Harbor like it
doesn't
match uh
so I booked them and I ran into my boss
office and I was like the golden night
is coming it's going to be awesome and
she's like no what are you doing you
clearly can't have this person coming
here and I was like oh and she's like
call them back immediately and I was
like but I didn't take their
number so so the golden I had to come no
matter what
so I kind of I kind of messed up so the
captain of the gold I showed up and did
you have to go forward and talk to him
no I had already been fired at that
point really yeah I wasn't even allowed
to and and and actually that wasn't the
first kind of misdemeanor that happened
at the harbor was
it you're making me say
this uh yeah I never took taken a [__]
at the floor before but I did take a
[__] at the floor in the Harbor before
before I got the job at working at the
harbor there had been an accident at the
harbor because they had public toilets
and we were usually part we usually uh
party pretty close in the harbor and and
I had eaten something weird that night
what was it I think it was my friend
that put laxatives in like the Beet
sauce do you have be beet sauce bernes
bernes sorry Bern sauce he every it was
like what is it called when everyone
brings something to a party
food uh I don't know call it a not a
knit party everyone brings something
right right I brought the steak my
cousin brought the Beret sauce he put up
I knew my cousin he would definitely put
something in the bar baroness sauce yeah
he put lexitas in that [__] I felt it a
few hours later at the party I'm like
okay I need to [__] right now or else
I'm going to [__] myself in front of
everyone so I ran I never ran to taking
a ship before it was that state of
emergency I even thought like should I
just go behind the Cars outside I'm like
no the toilets are right there I can
make it and then there's a huge line in
front of the in front of the toilets and
I'm like guys this is an emergency I
need to go and no one listened to me I'm
like what are you doing this is
important so I kind of just ran in
anyway and finally I find a toilet
because I had a Lo the door had a lock
on it but I opened the door and it was a
shower
and my my my butthole had already
decided the fate of what was going to
happen in that room no matter what the
room it was so I squatted down and took
a [__] in the shower a massive [__] in
the
shower and uh I obviously later I got I
got a job at that very Harbor and they
would always tell the story about the
man that took a [__] in the shower and I
would always go like that's horrible how
could anyone do that but I also try to
play Devil's Advocate a little bit like
maybe he was just having a bad day maybe
he ate something
bad um so yeah it was funny that was my
Inn you know even though I got fired
well I took a [__] in the shower and you
had to clean it so it's okay when did
you last go back for half a well
obviously now I can never go back
clearly so actually they have a great
restaurant I love to go back every time
time I can and so back to the trip to
Italy y you got fired and had you been
planning to go before you got fired or
was it getting fired no I got I got re
relocated so I just worked in the shop
instead pretty much so I was fine I was
still making a living but it was a bit
humiliating everyone was like yeah you
blew it where does this fit in the
timeline with the hot dogs um the hot
dogs is after so
yeah I met Maria we realized we wanted
to be together but I didn't have any
money like that planing tickets are
expensive and for us to keep staying
together they we wouldn't be able to
afford it so I realized I needed a
job um and at this time I also realized
I don't want to keep studying at this
University I I really hated it it the
worst time ever what so bad about it
well
because the first two weeks of
university is we have something called
ning where you're supposed to just oh
it's kind of like hazing I guess yeah
first two weeks hazing optional I'm like
well I'm not going to go if it's
optional I'll see you guys in two weeks
I'll be playing video games and then I
come back in two weeks and like all the
friend groups are already made and
there's just me like all right not
fitting in
anywhere and it was just you the only
one that sat out yeah yeah exactly so I
felt like such an outsider in this huge
group of people I didn't know where to
fit in and what is Swedish hazing like
you just drink a lot cuz I think over
here they have like freshes we which I
don't think there's I think it's just
the drinking not any of the crazy other
well you dress up and you do all this
weird [__] right and I was just kind of
like in a I don't want to do that kind
of mood which obviously then led to like
I had no friends I it like I didn't know
how to do it all these simple things of
like where do I sit what do I do during
the five minutes break they became like
a huge problem and I I just hated going
there just for the social aspect of it
expression called Billy no mates like
how long before you made a
friend I had some friends I did but I
never really connected that well
especially because I was I didn't care
about school
like I got into that University not for
my grades but because uh because I blew
my grades on video games but I did a an
entrance exam over a year and that got
me in so I got into one of the best
schools you need at top grades and
everything like so I'm in this school
with just people that really are
passionate about their school workor
where I'm just like I just want to play
games I I just it didn't make any sense
did you learn anything from there from
that school that you use today or
currently in your life uh no no physics
is good though it was making physics and
math and I I think physics is
interesting in a way but no no I thought
economy would come useful but no
definitely not no it's kind of
frustrating I wish I had better
knowledge on YouTube and I started
something film related instead because
I'm so clueless
obviously but yeah I hated school
because of of those two things like
wrong group of people I was such an
outsider every day just going I was just
a pain in the ass some people get to a
point in life where they want to go back
and go to university as an adult do you
see there's anything that could draw you
back any other interest behind games no
no [__] that I would never want to go
back it was so bad and I remember this
one course which is Matt lab or
whatever I hated it it was like Pro
programming math it's the worst I didn't
understand it I thought I was like okay
at least if I put my mind to it I can do
it I'm like I can't do this I'm not
smart enough it's too hard I can't do it
what am I doing here so I quit and my
parents's like all right well you're
we're not going to pay for you to be
around like you're going to have to pay
us rent then if because or whatever
which it might seem strict but I think
it's it's pretty fair and uh so I was
like all right I'll get a job whatever
no big deal it's really hard to get a
job actually turns out
especially uh if you're um really just
want one quick and you have no
connections so I I was I was so
desperate to prove my parents wrong like
I can get a job so I got a job uh
selling hot
dogs and uh it wasn't that bad it wasn't
that bad they had the catch of it was
that it was right next to my university
like across the street of my University
but it was sort of like the odd Street
of it so it wasn't like super popular
but every once in a while someone from
my class which I clearly didn't even
know but they knew who I was saw me
there and there was like oh you're here
now
cool the school were literally like
anyone that finish it will become like a
boss or whatever and then there's me and
the hot dog then and uh you didn't
interfere with any their hot dogs or
anything that wasn't vengeful or
spiteful no funny enough
my old teacher came once my old teacher
and he pretended that he didn't know it
was me yeah and I was like dude I'm not
embarrassed come on but no he pretended
he didn't know me I guess he thought it
was so embarrassing did you bit cringey
and I guess he didn't expect to see you
there yeah did he believe in you did he
think you were going to go far no I
don't think so he was a very good
teacher [__]
him um did you get to a point where you
could think you could never eat another
hot dog as long as you live no I made
hit great hot dogs what's the secret to
a great food well actually I just made
hamburgers we sold hamburgers as well
well what we did with the hot dogs
because the guy that worked there was so
cheap or not that's it's not right he
was
resourceful so he was like don't cook
the hot dogs cuz if we make too many
we're going to have to throw them away
so just microwave them dip them in the
in the in the water and people don't
know the
difference yeah it was pretty gross and
that's what you did yeah he told me to
do
it am I
guilty do have you ever been back to the
hot dog stand no but I really should
visit it again my it was funny cuz like
the boss in the harbor hated me she
hated me she was so nice to everyone
like high-fiving them and I was like
okay okay but this guy really liked me
cuz I was I was um you did what you were
told yeah clearly I dipped the [__]
thing I did it you must have saved him a
load of
money yeah especially on the scarce
napkin control that I did as well not
give out too
many uh but yeah no he really liked me
so I honestly even though the job was
[__] the fact I had a great boss was was
pretty good actually and he would follow
my YouTube thing as well like I I showed
it to him and he's like who that's
really cool it started some money in
there and I'm like yeah if people get
big they can make a lot of money and
he's like oh that's really cool and I
was like yeah uh because that was
clearly my dream at that point for it to
grow so I can make a living of it and
then boom I got my contract with the
network so I made no money a year making
YouTube videos to a a great amount of
money in one you know second essentially
because no ads and then I had ads on my
videos so I was like well
goodbye I
remember man this is terrible I
shouldn't be saying this but I never
told him I was quitting because I felt
so bad about
it so and I was supposed to meet Marat
so I was flying to uh Maria the next day
and I had just dropped off the keys and
then I was Landing in Amsterdam um in
between and I checked my phone and he
had called me like 10 times and I was
like I'll have to call him and then he
was crying that a fact that I had quit
and it was just so
sad yeah I'm sorry if you're I'm sorry I
don't remember your name
but we made some great hot dogs
together so in that moment when you were
talking to him about it being the there
being a future in it like what was the
moment where you realized there might be
a future in
YouTube uh for me the moment I realized
uh um well I I always dreamed big with
YouTube like I really thought maybe you
know there's a chance even though how
stupid it was CU it it was so unlikely
but I uh I think even when I just
started it was really weird cuz
uh a lot of people of my friends and
Friends I met through YouTube they
treated me like I was a big shot on
YouTube even before I had like 100 subs
or whatever how come I don't I don't
know I think people believe that I I had
a voice that was different and people
felt like this guy is going to get big
someday so people treated me like I'm
I'm something special but really I was
like 100 Subs like I didn't mean [__] uh
but I felt that Vibe since the beginning
I really did so I felt like I had a lot
to give and I was ready for for it and
and what was it can you like what was it
like when you got those first when you
reached that first Milestone of 100
Subs um the fir when I got 100 Subs it
was because um well I I had like 30 Subs
before that and then someone put me in
their subbox which back then was like a
big deal because then anyone that subed
to them will automatically sub to your
subbox so it's a great way to get
subscribers I don't give a [__] about
you but you get the number number so all
of a sudden overnight I got 100 100 subs
and I was like holy [__] this I'm going
to be the biggest
YouTuber um so that was crazy I remember
100 Subs is like the biggest deal one of
my big that was probably one of my
biggest Milestones just getting a 100
and did it change at all the kind of the
way you approach making your videos with
the idea that actually there is a a
larger group of people who are watching
what do you what well like before you
was saying that you were making videos
like without any idea of who you were
talking to yeah but now you had a
defined idea of how many people
well I didn't I still didn't know like
yeah I had a couple people watching me
but I didn't feel like I had an audience
yet I would say it was more like trying
to grab people across everywhere as many
people as I can just to have an audience
but I didn't feel like I had it yet no I
didn't do the hey how's it going bro or
anything like that back then cuz the
Bros became my audience I think that's
when it started
really and and when did that when did
you start to like what is the story
behind the key pieces of it like for
instance the the Bro Army like when did
that crystallize for
you
um it started with uh when I started
playing Amnesia cuz I would when in my
first episode of Amnesia I literally say
I'm not going to make any jokes
because that takes away the atmosphere
or
whatever I just wanted to get scared and
a lot of people hold me against that
they're like oh you changed you said you
weren't going to make jokes but then the
I started making jokes and I thought it
was so funny how you can turn around
horror to Comedy in a way that mix is
something I haven't really seen before
especially playing games so I thought
that was so interesting and I wanted to
do more of that and then so I would
start as a way to feel less scared I
would call the monster like my bro what
up bro how come at me bro or what come
at me bro that's where it came from come
at me bro that mean then I was like I'll
call my audience Bros that makes
sense make them feel like close to me or
whatever like we're a community and I
think that really work and when you had
a small amount of subscribers did you
actively communicate more more in the
comments I I would do I so I started
doing Frid Friday with PewDiePie that
sort of became my way to communicate
with my audience in a way I I would just
do something to kind of acknowledge that
people were
watching and and what kind of did you
develop any kind of personal connections
with any of the fans early on in the
early
subscribers no do you still get people
writing to you say I've been with you
since everyone everyone says they've
been with forever I can't never take
that seriously because then you check on
their profile and they they're like I've
been watching you well first of all
people go like I've been watching you
for8 years but I'm like dude I've been
making videos six years what are you
talking about and then you see other
people be like I watch you for four
years and then you like watch when they
no they say I've been subscribed for
four years and then you check their
profile and then like created in 2016
you're like come on so I can never tell
when to take it seriously but if I meet
a fan that I can tell like sometimes I
do meetups or whatever I can tell from
what they say that they are like really
old school that's always was really cool
when you got that first check from the
network and you were able to step away
from the hot dog stand yeah did the
amount of happiness in your life change
overnight oh yeah that that was one of
the most surreal moments ever the the
thought that I had made my my my dream
come true essentially that uh I could
make a living doing this cuz that was
really my dream that was my goal I
didn't save to anyone obviously but uh
when it happened I was it was such
unreal moment like I I remember tearing
up a little bit even just thinking about
it and had that been your plan to
partner with a network like was that
your next step well YouTube wouldn't
partner channels that did gaming back
then so yeah I had to I knew I had to
get a network partnership and I didn't
even get it directly I got it through a
friend that I didn't know like I very
loose contact gave me this contract to
this company that was responsible for
for my living I had no contact with
whatsoever I was just hoping the shcks
would come in every week or every
month and and how did you approach the
kind of contract and all that kind of um
part of it I mean did you feel like
confident about the business side of it
from the
start no I didn't I didn't even know
what the contract said like my contract
was
illegal it was didn't it said like this
word that I didn't know what it meant it
was like in in Forever what is the word
in indefinite in no it wasn't indefinite
it's like a legal term for forever right
that I showed my lawyer like a year
perpetuity imp perpetuity that's it it
was an imp perpetu contract and I'm like
I don't know I'm Swedish like my English
wasn't even good back then I'm like I
don't know what what this means and then
my dad set me up with a lawyer and he's
like wait a minute
uh so yeah we figured out it was an
illegal contract cuz you're not allowed
to have
that but for the time being it gave you
the confidence do you think to be able
to continue making videos well the thing
is like the contract that I that I had
everyone's first contract on YouTube
it's a scam it's a piece of [__] you get
you you lose half your revenue or
something like that but you're like oh
my God I can make a living off YouTube
this is amazing back then as well I
think the
ad sense was a bit higher as well so
even though I didn't have that many
people watching me I could still make a
living I think I had like 15 15 million
views per
month and and so the journey then was
you went to Italy for a bit and is that
where you were living uh when you really
started to uh grow as a Channel or no no
I was in Sweden during the time M say
had come with me to to Sweden and we uh
uh I same thing there my parents were
like it's not that easy to get a flight
I'm
like they were right so I couldn't get a
flight and my girlfriend was coming to
live with me and I was like what do I do
and I wasn't making any money yet at
this time like I I was still my living
was still not from
YouTu yet I knew it was coming I knew
this contract was coming so Maria fell
in love with the hot dog salesman yeah
definitely
Ely but she yeah she came over to uh to
Sweden to to live with me for about
eight months and we had to live in the
suburb and me uh I would always make fun
of kids living in the
suburb cuz I went to I went to a rich
school and we would always make fun of
the people that put their name you had
to write where you live and I was always
like oh you live in the
suburb we always make fun of that one
kid then live in the suburb but it was
great I had a great time there it was
very nice uh very uh I think that was a
very humbling moment uh cuz we we didn't
have any money we uh we were fighting
over like I remember once we were
fighting over a pack of noodles Me and
Mar this is this deal to get three
noodles for two and I went for the deal
but Mar was like but I want the deal too
I was like we can't afford
it it was like 2 or 3 lbs or something
like that and did you go from being PM
Pals um to actually living together yeah
pretty much yeah we went very fast
together but it worked out really well
like that actually cuz when you when you
have a relationship I I say that because
I I think you can only get so far
talking to each other online uh but when
you have when you start off a
relationship like
that uh I think it has a stronger uh uh
Foundation
um cuz you even though you never met you
know you really care for each other what
was the first time you ever met her like
that extremely awkward yeah cuz she's
very shy I'm a bit shy she's not used to
speak in English and we see each other
for the first time it was very awkward
where did you first lay eyes on
her uh when I exit the oh I remember so
I was at the pl
we we had just landed and I was like
what am I doing here this is crazy I
didn't even want to get off the plane at
one point it was so scary and then yeah
I saw her um when I got up and yeah she
was even more beautiful U but it was
very awkward but I remember even
thinking like oh jeez have I made a
mistake here cuz it was so awkward
between us the first couple
like hour at least the first hour where
she would put her
uh head on my shoulder which meant me
think okay this is kind of nice and
then after a few hours it really just
kind of dropped and we were just back to
like as if we
were on distance yeah exactly
yeah and what's the kind of Secret of of
having a relationship like that with
somebody who you
um you know have an incredible
partnership with and and and can see you
can get through thick and
thin I don't know if there's a secret I
think if you really care for each other
it just sort of works itself out really
um she's been with me throughout most of
this journey so she she knows me she's
supported me and we understand each
other in that way so she moved to Sweden
to be with you but like before that
where was what was her journey where was
her life going Mar was supposed to study
University and her the plan was that she
was just going to you know take a leap
year is that what it's called Gap year
Gap year she was going to take a gap
here to just go to Sweden with me and
then go back studying eventually but
then she started making videos as well
and that sort of became her thing and
just kind of step by step like we didn't
really plan for anything we just knew we
wanted to be together this is the really
the only
way there there's a myth that says that
you know anytime you see a camera move
in one of her videos you're the one
that's operating the camera do you shoot
all of her videos every single one yeah
no I shot all her videos a lot of times
she she thinks I'm a really bad
photographer like I'm the worst
photographer of all time but I see the
comments and they're always like oh your
videos look so nice who shot this you
know it's me there's no no one else so
when when did she decide to start making
videos what was the conversation
like
um so Mar wanted to start making videos
cuz she was start watch watching other
people as well and she got inspired to
do it and um she was a dog sitter in
Sweden which isn't really like a proper
job really I mean I'm saying that
because I had to do all the work for
it like that was equally my job as hers
what were the names of some of the dogs
good Stu that [__] dog it was worse
than Edgar piece of [__] like this this
puppy that was so
annoying wa the owner would drop off at
like 6:00 a.m. and I was so tired I was
going to die and then this dog would
just not let us sleep and it was yeah
good
Stu I hope you're less of an [__] I
want gustar to meet
Edgar that' be fun when did you first
meet Edgar
like 3 years ago four years ago yeah
where did you find him we found edar at
a farm about an hour from here worst
mistake of my life should have should
have known then cuz he was like crazy
then and we thought oh he's so cute just
like everyone else that sees him oh he's
so cute and then we brought him back on
the train and he just wouldn't sit still
the whole ride and we were like oh maybe
he's nervous because he left his home or
whatever and then we we got home and he
wouldn't sit still the whole time and
then we went to sleep and he wouldn't he
wouldn't stop he would take shits
everywhere and pee everywhere and I
called the owner and I was like I can't
take care of this dog I can't just can't
do it and she it was kind of
like you know in movies when there was
like a witch that sells you something
bad or something like that like I'm not
going to return him you can't return him
and she's like I'm glad I got rid of him
she literally said that and I was just
like
what I realized I was stuck with this
[__]
dog and who came first Edo or Maya we
had Maya first we've got Maya in Sweden
she's our budget dog she had one eye she
was so cheap and she's so but we love
her because she was so she was already
trained she's old so she's very easy to
take care of she almost take care of us
in a way do you know what happened to a
a c scratched her eye that's all we know
but we don't know if it's true or not
but so we thought hey another pug not a
problem big problem big problem and what
was it like between the two of them at
the start they were fine yeah no the
dogs are
fine um and then so back uh to the
noodles and to being in Sweden in the
suburbs yeah like how how long did that
last that was eight months we spent
eight months in Sweden and then during
those eight eight month my channel
really blew up like a big big difference
from where we were because I couldn't
afford paying rent almost at some point
I I kind of had to write the guy and be
like a month I'll get my check I promise
and it was really I want I needed to
tell my parents at that point like I
need money but I didn't want you know
obviously when you're young you don't
want to go to your parents for these
things anymore so I managed to solve it
managed to
uh wait a little bit I finally got my
YouTube check and I was able to pay rent
and uh my channel really really grew a
lot um I I got from that time to 100,000
subscribers which doesn't sound like a
lot but back then it was a lot as well
and as fast as he
went who's your favorite
YouTuber
uh I don't really have a favorite right
now of all
time well that'll that'll be me come on
there's no one better than
me no uh but you do love your own
videos love is a strong word it's more
like a they're okay I
guess yeah I love my videos I love
watching them they're really
funny if you had to if somebody like had
never heard of you or what you do before
you had to point at one video to say
this will give you an idea of what I'm
up to what would that video be I I
really need to make a video like that
cuz I don't have a video like that it's
so I guess that's why people don't
really know what I do anymore cuz like
it's not a clear thing I just do so many
different things it's not clear what I
do people still think I'm a gamer I
don't like half of my stuff is not
gaming so I don't know it keeps changing
so it's kind of hard to show if I was to
spin the question round like is there a
particular video that you think back on
as like super cringe that you wouldn't
want people to watch I think all my
videos past
2015 before 2015 yeah sorry before 2015
yeah don't watch those
please they're still there for the ad
Revenue obviously just kidding uh
yeah yeah have you ever had a thing
where you like really liked a person but
just not understood what they're doing
with their
videos yeah
definitely I think that's okay yeah
there's there's a difference between a
person and their content I think
definitely when when you were putting
together your own network with the Rev
mode project what did you look for in
creators when you figuring out what your
network would be with RM mod the goal
was to find people that
uh could all get along like like we
would hang out anyway sort of was the
idea because you can tell one thing I
learned early was when I did my very
first production PewDiePie in France how
extremely cringy it is to all of a
sudden be in front of a camera with
someone that you never met at least
someone like me like I'm not that
outgoing that I can just all right we're
best friends now like it was very
strange to collab with people that I
didn't know so I knew for us to form a
group we kind of just had to be people
that already get along and and how did
that PewDiePie and Friends project come
about uh well it's my network that said
hey we'll fly you in we pay you for your
show to get made um and I'm like oh
that's
cool it wasn't cool I think they were
just trying to squeeze out as many
episodes as possible it's like I think
we shot 30
episodes there's like four of them out
there should give you an idea
um I think that really showed it taught
me at least cuz I thought okay we're
stepping it up we got better cameras got
camera crew better lightning better uh
everything everything is more thought
out but it it really learned like that's
not the key to YouTube people just care
about the content or they want to be
entertained was that your first ever
experience with like a in verom as
professional setup yeah yeah that was my
first professional setup and it was
definitely like the reaction from the
that I got from my audience was like we
don't like this at all it's the first
time I got many dislikes on a video and
I'm
like what went wrong here and you think
you know in your head like oh this is
going to be awesome everyone's going to
love it but no was it even a good
experience for you personally to film it
I think it was good practice for me cuz
it's a very strange thing to be in front
of especially when you're just in a room
alone to then all of a sudden be in
front of other people you don't know and
with cameras cuz that's it's a weird
thing and I think it was good experience
to kind of break down that bit of
weirdness and did you meet anybody
through for instance that experience
that you still friends with
today well no I mean I already knew Ken
how did you actually that was the first
time we met during that show yeah me and
Ken met the first time he flew in to be
on that show uh yeah and we spent a lot
of time together it was really fun what
what made you hit off with Ken in the
first place
uh yeah why I oh yeah so Ken so I did
these uh shout out competitions Ken
hates this but he was one of the winners
I didn't even pick him I was going
through the submissions uh and Mara was
like what about him and I was like I
don't know I don't really like him but I
was like okay fine I'll pick him and
then Ken won obviously and he got like a
big not that big uh but some subscriber
boost and he made a thank you video
about it and I I didn't really know much
about him but I saw that thank you video
and I was like oh he seemed like a
really cool guy and I think we just
started talking like very
lightly and ever since I think we just
been friends but yeah shooting this this
Pewdiepie and friends as [__] as it was
it was really fun to just [__] about
with k that was a really good time was
that the first time you ever went to Los
Angeles yeah it was the first time for
both of us I think it's really fun and
and after that experience did you think
that you wouldn't do any more like
professional kind of shows
again I guess not no I didn't think I
would do more after that I I kind of
learned if the one thing I took from
that was like people don't care about
all this fuss people just want to be
entertained and anything that takes away
from the quality that is in my normal
videos they're going to notice and
they're going to hate
it how how has your attitude to
Preparing a video changed from from from
back then to
now uh back then well it's funny cuz
people always reference my old videos
with a bit of nostalgia as in like oh
his old videos are so great he was so
much funnier and like so much better
but they were so [__] like I don't see
that at all especially cuz I know it cuz
I would literally just press record
shoot 10 minutes stop recording upload
like there's no thought there was no
effort there was just me playing the
game but maybe maybe there's a charm in
that I guess but there was also like
this thing where I could get stuck on a
puzzle in the game for literally like
three episodes
and I I my thing was like I never cut I
don't cut so this is these painful Parts
where people literally screaming at me
like it's so obvious what the [__] is
wrong with you it was even the first
PewDiePie meme was PewDiePie it's so
obvious because that's what all people
would
comment uh because I wouldn't cut my
videos but now I like to sort of write
down an idea what I have I run it
through in my head sometimes S I even go
through different parts of it before
just to make sure it works I want I
wanted to have a structure where it has
like you know a beginning something has
to be important in the middle and then
it has to end in a sort of nice way and
that feels like a package more nice
video to watch rather than I'm playing
okay now I stop um so I think it's a lot
of
difference and where does the kind of
inspiration come from for for videos
you're going to make
I think it comes from anywhere I really
try and open my
mind it's I I I don't know
I I get inspired by a lot of other the
YouTubers in these things I think you
you watch them and you're like oh if
they can make it entertaining I can
probably do it too not to be naive or
whatever but I think a lot of YouTubers
they look at other people and be like oh
that looks fun I want to try and do that
might spin on that um so it's a bit
hypocritical of what I said before
but uh I think that's how it works on
YouTube you you kind of look at other
people and you want to do try the same
thing um it's not
like anyone that ever played Happy
Wheels just thought I'm going to play
Happy Wheels just because I think it's a
great idea not because I watched someone
else play it like they play because they
saw someone else play it and they want
to play it who's the first person to
play I don't know the first but I know
Uber hex or Noah was probably one of the
first Bigg ones and by the
way when I played Happy Wheels the first
time people hated it they thought it was
the worst [__] ever like go back to
playing horror games this is
garbage and I was like oh man that sucks
but I really enjoyed it and I thought it
was really funny so I just kept doing it
and it became my most popular show ever
like my most popular series ever on
YouTube that's also a thing I learned
which was like you shouldn't always
listen to listen to to your audience you
should 100 it's a you can't explain it
but you should 100% listen to everything
your audience says and you should 100%
not do that as
well and I can't tell you when it's the
right time and wrong time to do that cuz
it's weird because so many people think
YouTube's such a success because of how
reactive you can be to what your
audience want to see yeah um if if I
listen to my audience 100% I would not
be where I am I I I know know that
cuz I realized I W point cuz back then
it was my thing to play horror games and
uh there weren't many horror games back
then there was like a handful I'm not
joking like there was not many horror
games I'd lose indie horror games like
the scary ones uh I had literally
scavenged every single [__] horror
game to keep up this thing that I'm just
playing horror games so I knew like I
had to find something else if I want to
keep doing this as my thing I have to do
something else I have to try out
different things
um fans don't look at it that way they
just want the same thing no matter what
which you know fair enough but that's
not how it works and also personally
every day just being like hey how's it
going
ah it was very very frustrating at some
points just keep getting scared all the
time that expectation as well but you
you think you had a really it was a
great response for the recent uh
Resident Evil
series this one was it like yeah to go
back into our game yeah no I'm still
trying my best to maintain all the
aspects that I've done I still try and
play horror games every once in a while
whenever there's one that I find really
interesting instead of playing the
shitty ones over and over and over
because I know they might ask for that
but that's not what they
want so the way that you've kind of made
make videos and the videos themselves
have evolved so much in the last several
years what do you think is next how do
you foresee that you're going to evolve
what you do on your channel
further well I'm done this is
it I don't know
um I there's different things I want to
do I think the fun aspect is something I
learned is what matters the most if I'm
having fun doing it uh
that's really all that matters and I
always I don't know where I'll end up
and I didn't know where I'll end up back
then but I know I want to keep doing
there just just for the future what do
you think about like The Wider evolution
of of YouTube and YouTube videos as a
medium in what sense like where do you
think it's going like what where the
idea of creators where where do you
think what's next for that it's weird
it's weird because we're still we're
still so small even though we're big or
whatever YouTubers aren't
really taking that seriously still I
think compared to how big our audiences
are um YouTube isn't really I thought it
would be
more advanced or further on at this
point cuz you can tell where YouTube is
going it's going to keep growing it's
going to keep getting bigger but
um I I'm surprised how how it still is
in at the same time
so I don't know I don't know it's weird
where is it going to go if if you were
to wake up tomorrow morning as the CEO
of YouTube what kind of changes would
you make to the platform would be where
do you think it needs to go next I mean
see YouTu that seems like a hard job to
do honestly with so many people
involved um I don't know if I want to do
that but uh I don't know I
think
um for me as someone that has an
audience I find it very important that I
talk to them directly to kind of let
them know what is happening and I think
YouTube as a website should be thinking
about it in the same way as in they have
so many people that use their
website but
they're just a company they don't really
have a way to really communicate with
the people that use their website and
love their website and really care about
their website but I it's such
a wall in between I think YouTube and
the people that use the website and I
think I would try and break down that
wall when in last December in 2016 when
you said you were going to delete your
channel your you know people thought it
was going to be the main Channel yeah
was there any truth in
that
uh yeah a little a little bit of Truth
yeah definitely I think I was feeling a
bit fed up with CU I always prided
myself in that a lot of people all my
fans were active or whatever like if I
had 100,000 Subs I would get 100,000
views on my video or even more and that
was kind of important to me cuz I was
like yeah well I may not have many
subscribers but at least they all watch
me now I've been doing YouTube for so
long and you know so many people
subscribe and so many things happen like
I don't get 53 million views on each
video that would be great by the way but
um so I thought it was really like when
you got more bigger numbers than you
ever expected you kind of stop caring I
know it might seem ungrateful that's not
it at all it's more like I know in a
way 54 million it is actually 54 million
subscribers is insane and is a something
really
big but uh I really just care more about
my audience in a way
that I'd rather just have a small
Channel and kind of [__] off in no way I
I don't think I realized what it meant
really to be the biggest Channel I think
so I was kind of I think at that time
specifically I was very fed up with
it when when did you become number one
and what was that what happened on that
day uh was 2014 I
think um and uh I don't remember I think
I was in Los Angeles at the time I I've
heard a story from someone else about um
you actually being with smos on that day
yeah it wasn't on the day though but I
SM was the previous biggest channel so
we shot a video together where we they
kind of passed the crown to me or
whatever uh I I smash was actually one
of the first channels I watched on
YouTube I used to love those guys I
still do obviously but uh they they
inspired me I think in a bit way because
I thought it was so cool so yeah very
very unreal if you could
um
articulate why you think
the the channel has the popularity it
does and and experiences the growth that
it does how would you describe it
h it's always kind of weird to me
because
uh I if you meet me um it's a very
different experience than if you watch
my video and uh I think that
um
what was the question I don't want to
get too sidetracked just really like I
was just asking if you to describe like
basically why you think the CH is such a
success um I think there's a couple
different reasons uh I I would have to
say luck because of timing and all that
stuff would I be as big if I started
today probably not
um but
also I think what's the word
commitment I've done videos every single
day as best as I can since I started and
I think that grind has really you you
don't get 53 million Subs in a day uh
you built that over years and years and
years and that's what I've done uh I
think I no one really cared about my
videos until I did something that was
different I found my own thing which was
the horror games that was the first time
people said I want to see more when is
the next one coming up so and and I see
so many people especially when I do
these subscriber competitions everyone
does the same thing they just do what
everyone else is doing no one really
cares and there's too many people doing
that so I think I did my own thing I did
it for a long time and I was
lucky but then you you still sometimes
do get involved with the various memes
and stuff that happened on YouTube
because you feel it's important to to
sort of make light of them or memes well
like for instance smash or pass or
whatever yeah I just need a video that
day what are you talking about just
smash or pass that's a great title I'll
take that [__] can I make it funny yeah
absolutely I'll make anything funny if I
need
to yeah and so like where where did the
idea to do the Photoshop videos come
from
uh well I thought I would play on my I
think that goes on the do my own thing
cuz I don't know not that sure a lot of
people are good at Photoshop but I don't
think that many people are so I thought
at least then I can bring my own
expertise and expertise um and do
something different so it just made
sense in a way and when did you first
meet a subscriber in real
life it must have been in when we were
in Pula in Sweden
I don't remember when though but
probably I remember I would get
recognized in that area more and more by
all
the young Swedish Lads in the area and
uh yeah it was very cool very different
it's so strange cuz
like even now when I get recognized like
we me and Marcy were out this week and
and I just forgot that I'm a public
figure cuz I get sto I got stopped and
they there's a line just waiting to take
pictures of me in this clothes store and
I'm like oh yeah this is the life I have
I forgot about that CU we tend to kind
of move in areas that doesn't get too
crazy but
yeah there have been like a few people
before who've been YouTube creators who
have um kind of had instances where the
pressure of um having to make videos
having to uh keep supplying content for
Their audience and also
the directness of the comments and the
personal nature sometimes of the
trolling has led to them kind of um
having some difficult times have you um
have you ever how do you deal with with
the comments how do you deal with all
the attention how do you stay
centered o um I try and listen try and
fil through out what is actual criticism
and what's actually trolling or whatever
I think it's pretty important to even
though because a lot of people brush off
hate like oh I don't listen or whatever
but I I think it's been important for me
to kind
of grow in a way to kind of listen to
what some stuff are they're actually is
criticism I think you have to have an
open mind to that but I also think you
have to have a strong
[Music]
mind I see I I met a lot of people yeah
that just can't cope with it it's too
much for them and I understand
understand that I really do cuz um it is
a lot
definitely um to every single move you
make you're going to be judged for like
I'll be judged for every single upload I
I make everything single thing I
say uh and that can be very frustrating
it can ruin your day in a way if you
feel like you messed up or whatever but
you get over it and then you move on and
you make another
video um but it's definitely not forever
everyone
no do you think there'll come a time
where you won't want to make a video
every single day for the
channel
um obviously yeah I mean I can't keep
doing it
forever um am I going to be here when
I'm 50 or whatever who knows I don't
think so um I think a lot of my fans are
already kind of like how long is he
going to keep doing
this so so that's already not a good
sign but I I still really love it and I
what else would I do like I I love doing
it maybe I'll do it differently in a way
that's doesn't take up so much time and
effort because it really does at this
point uh but I think I would always want
to keep some part of it there yeah do
you think if you were to start a family
that you would involve the family in the
videos um well I mean that's the golden
ticket to YouTube you get a baby that's
like views come on
no all how will you know it's time to do
something
else when I when I find something that I
enjoy more than
YouTube but if you were making YouTube
videos every single day when will you
have a chance to find that something
else uh I still do other stuff outside
of YouTube at this point like I'm still
trying to I've worked on a lot of other
projects outside of YouTube obviously
not as committed and it can never be the
same thing I can never put that full
commitment in it which can can be
frustrating
but no there's definitely things did you
get the same kind of feeling from um
releasing a game like Tu simulator as
you do from creating videos for your
channel yeah definitely seeing all the
EXC I think yeah sharing something that
you worked on is the same thing seeing
people's reaction to it that's the the
great thing it wouldn't be the same
without the audience the reaction I I
still read com comments on all my videos
and it's not because I want to torture
myself I'm kidding but uh it's cuz I
enjoy it it's fun um what was it like to
come outside your house and find a
reporter from The Wall Street Journal
there well I never actually saw them I
just heard them at the
door um but I wish I saw
them it was a very bizarre time uh when
all that was happening it's was a bit
like it's not the first time I have a
report at my door so I knew how to
handle it for sure why why did they come
before well there was one guy that had
flew in from like Mississippi or some
[__] he was just knocking on my he was
from ESPN or some something and he was
just like pretending to be a mailman and
then he was all of a sudden in my face
and then I was like fine I'll just walk
my dog with you for 10 minutes and he
got what he wanted I guess um and yeah I
had reporters ringing my door at other
points and I'm like how did you get my
address this is so weird it's really
weird um
so it was all right it wasn't as bad I
think a lot of people saw that tweet I
did because I was like Wall Street
journalist at my house blah blah blah
people like oh my God that's not okay
that's terrible I'm like I don't
care do you remember the first interview
you ever gave
uh yeah yeah Sweden Sweden local
newspaper Y what was the headline I
don't remember I don't remember but
PewDiePie has blah blah blah subscribers
probably yeah do you keep articles and
stuff like that uh my mom kept some of
them but not really no I have the the
only ones I have the only one I have is
the Times article I
think yeah what was the kind of
experience to like going on to the Late
Show with Steven Kar had you watched
that show ever before no the thing was
like people kept saying Steven Kar this
is a huge deal for you Felix you don't
understand I'm like I don't want to go
like I don't know who this guy
is
I had no clue now I watched him as I
love him he was amazing but uh at the
time I was like I I think that really
help because I didn't seem that nervous
at that interview as I was on Conan
because I know who Conan was so I was
just like oh my God but Co I it helped
me kept my cool because I didn't know
who who he was so it didn't feel like a
big deal but I remember before going on
stage obviously very nervous my family
was there and all that stuff but it's
really cool
how do you find those type of interviews
with the press and with with hosts like
that what what kind of like is there a
is there a a Persona that you kind of
have to slip into or no I think it's
weird cuz uh I uh I don't which I think
is almost like the problem
CU um there is a clear I never thought I
had a persona but I it is clear
difference between PewDiePie and fix
um you know when I make these videos
where I go outside I scream naked in a
suit or whatever that's clearly
PewDiePie Felix would never be able to
do that like I have to kind of enter
that character I think with interviews I
tend to just stay as Felix because he
makes more sense
um and that part of me is always more
like okay I
guess um so yeah yeah tend to be more
relaxed and and how going forward how
will you approach doing interviews and
relations with the media and
stuff um well I remember actually here
in UK the sun wrote to me and I didn't
know that the sun was like this uh bad
rep unreputable or what it's called like
uh yeah not not very tabloid it's a
tabloid yeah and um I didn't know I just
knew they had a lot of readers I'm like
oh that's cool the sun that's sounds
good so I did the interview and it took
like a long time like it took a couple
hours and I have to make videos like
it's a big commitment for me I know it
doesn't seem like it but uh to do that
and then to then just see the headline
the day after
being this is how much money he makes
which is something we never even talked
about in like these few hours you know I
thought I was there to tell my story and
then you just see that and I was kind of
like what the [__] like that's really
disgusting like that's what you took out
of that we didn't even talk about
that um so that was very frustrating and
I think it just kept going from there
like even with Wall Street journals our
first article was about money anytime I
see my name it's about money and I
understand that that's interesting to
people but like beating it to death
always always always and it always
became a thing where people started
asking me just to antagonize me about it
as well like you can tell that they were
like I'm going to be rude now how much
money do you make and it's
like you wouldn't ask anyone else that
you wouldn't ask any other public figure
that question but for some reason it's
okay to ask me and it just feels like
all
right I think there's a difference in
the kind of perception of um you know I
think it's new what you do and people
getting paid for it is new and I think
people people don't understand that you
can get paid to do it it so the fact
that I make a lot of money doing it is
so shocking to people and they want to
get that out there I I get it I
understand why but it's like okay we've
done it 100 times now like we talk about
other stuff as
well was there ever a point in this
where it became about the money you know
doing seven videos a week was there a
time where it was like was that ever a
big motivation no no I don't think so I
I honestly like you people probably call
me out and think it's [__] but like
you can take away many zeros from my pay
check I would still do it like I did it
even when I didn't make money so clearly
I did it out of
passion uh don't get me wrong like money
is great and it's a great security
especially when you weren't able to pay
rent and that feeling of stress that you
have around that fighting with the
noodles yeah fighting fighting over
noodles having to look after Gustav
having to look at after shitty dogs
gusta
and then yeah
um to to then have that security is so
it's great to have no doubt and I know I
complain a lot about all these things
like money or whatever that's all people
talk about like it's a problem but it
there are worse things clearly do you
when you're thinking about the ideas for
your videos do is how shocking people um
and triggering people ever something
that comes into mind as a reaction you
want to get
no it's never an idea it's I think most
of my uh jokes that I got in trouble for
has just been something that kind of
slips out because a lot of it you know I
don't yes I have an outline of what I
want to say and do but I'll Never follow
it and it's always just random and then
something comes out and you're like I
wasn't supposed to say that but it came
out really funny and then you watch it
and and I always laugh like I always
think it's hilarious and I know a lot of
people think so too but there's always
that that that one or whatever how many
people that will react a different way
and I always feel like it's a shame I I
don't make the joke to kind of piss
people off like that's not the goal but
um it's an inevitability and I do like
to push boundaries I do like to see
where you can go with things I think
that's really
interesting
but
yeah do you think that if you had more
censorship and had used less profanity
that you would have established the same
connection with your
audience no no I think people
want honesty they they wouldn't have a
connection to me if I wasn't honest to
them and I think if I censor
myself you you know even my videos now
they are
censored you may not believe it but like
a lot of it is cut out because we know
it doesn't fit and we know people won't
you know it would start drama or
whatever but doing um like another video
that was kind of Hitler themed and had
you know the conam video the Hitler
history thing like do you feel like what
made you want to do that um after all of
the fuss that had come about from the
previous videos um I wanted to do that
video to show that
despite all the drama
I I could I wasn't going to censor
myself I don't really care for Nazi
jokes I think they're kind of like done
like it okay it was funny for a while um
but uh yeah I think with that video I
just wanted to show that look I can
still joke about these things I still
think you know despite everything that
happened you know my audience never had
a problem with the
humor uh because then they would have
you know call out call me out on it and
I just thought why should I censor
myself to to someone that is in my
audience and I kind of wanted to show
like I can still do this it doesn't
matter at this
point um it doesn't make a difference
but then if people that have more of a
distant kind of relationship to your
content and to you yeah see that and
think okay well that's you
legitimizing those kind of jok that
happened before and that maybe you do
have there is more to it than just
making Nazi jokes like does that concern
you I just strongly believe I I just
really don't believe that that's the
case I really don't believe that making
jokes
legitimizes
um that kind of you know Neo-Nazi thing
or whatever I really don't I don't see
that connection I know people will would
like to but I I don't I really don't and
maybe that's naive of me to
think but um I don't I don't see it and
what about if there were people like
what what would you say to people who
kind of looked at that and then kind of
felt just felt hurt by some of the stuff
uh in a way that you definitely didn't
intend but they felt that anyway I mean
what would what would you say to
them
um I don't know I guess I would I guess
I would say um you know sorry it's not
my intent to make anyone feel hurt
obviously from watching my videos has
never been a goal like I I that would be
kind of a stupid goal to make um my my
goal is entertain my goal is to make
people laugh that's what I really care
about that's where I really get a kick
out of when you make so many videos all
the time you you do make missteps here
and there and sometimes it doesn't work
clearly it's bound to happen but yeah
you know obviously if anyone feels hurt
I I genuinely feel sorry and I don't
want people to feel that way um yeah and
um like one of the other things I
thought was really interesting was that
when you started your company Revel mode
one of the core three things besides
creation of games and content was that
you wanted to do charity
initiatives um is this something that's
always been important to you or is it
something that has grown with the amount
of influence that you have it's not
always been important to me I didn't
really think about it much at all until
I there was this competition King of the
web which you would get like seven Grand
or something seven and a half Grand if
you were voted number
one which 7 and a half Grand that's a
lot of
money uh and
uh to win that kind of money from your
audience a lot of people did that and it
was really cool so I was like maybe I
should give it a go but it
felt greedy in a way to use your
audience to get more money like clearly
if you have an audience that is big
enough to make you win you have enough
you have enough that you don't need that
money so it just seemed kind of greedy
and I thought well can I turn this
around in a way and I thought okay well
what if I do it for a charity so I
looked into some Charities and and uh I
thought okay well this is a good cause
we'll do it to save the tigers or
whatever Tigers getting this thing so
why don't we do that and it were it
became like this really positive things
fans got even more engaged because it
was charity and it just turned this
thing that might seem a little
greedy uh into something really really
positive for the community and I thought
this is really cool I would love to do
more of this and that was that was
pretty early in my YouTube career and I
I was like I want to do more of this
this is really cool do you think that
YouTube is do enough for charity and for
issues I think you can't say that no
it's up to each each one what you want
to do it shouldn't be like you have to
do it I think that's the wrong approach
if you have something that you care
about and you want to you have the
audience I think it's a great
opportunity to to use that for good and
I think a lot of YouTubers do so much
for charity more than I've seen in a lot
a lot of other
communities
um and I think it's really cool to see
all the engagement I think enough well I
don't know what's enough but they
definitely do a lot yeah do you have
watch TV I don't have a TV license they
keep mailing me this you you you want to
pay us right I'm like no I don't I don't
need it so if if YouTube had never been
created yeah what do you think your PA
would have
been that's hard I don't know uh if
YouTube never was
created man it's funny looking back
because I almost got a job at an
advertising agency the biggest one in
Sweden as an U I don't know what the
term is but like low low down but it was
huge
opportunity uh was between one one guy
and another and I didn't get the job and
it was so crushing cuz I was like this
could have been my way out to do
something creative and I loved
Photoshop uh but then I was lucky enough
that I got YouTube I don't know where I
would have end up I I uh I do remember
like when you're at the age where you
haven't really figured out what you're
going to do with your life it's a it's a
really tough time I think not knowing
what you want to do I I remember how
unhappy I was compared to now so I
definitely wouldn't have been as happy
at
least and like what would you say to
creators that are starting out
now um depend depends what they want I
guess if you're starting off YouTube now
I say the same thing I said back then
which is like you need to find your own
thing I think
I'm I find that I'm always drawn to
YouTubers that do a different
thing it might not be your and I I
understand I remember I that frustration
of feeling like you have more to give
because it took a long time for me to
get bigger on YouTube like I did it for
a year and not a lot of people cared and
I remember I felt like I had so much to
give like I can do this I know I can and
that frustration was killing me so I
guess I would say say that to them like
just stay committed try and find your
own voice and hopefully you'll be
lucky does the channel That is going to
knock you off number one exist
today that's a good
question I guess I don't think anyone is
ever going to beat
[Laughter]
me